this podcast and every other podcast I
make is supported by patreon patreon
support has got a slightly extended
version of this particular episode which
I also do want to note before we go any
further may contain some very very
slight minor spoilers for God of War
Ragnarok as it relates to Freya pretty
early game stuff though otherwise
patreon supporters get extra content
including unedited q and A's add free
episodes of the podcast including audio
versions they are now exclusively on
patreon and the personal satisfaction of
knowing that you are helping a very
independently run selection of video
game podcasts so if you want to support
click the link in the description below
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of video game voice acting 101
I'm Alana this is Danielle we're here in
person this is very exciting it's very
cool we can actually be in the same room
together that's actually something to
make a note of Isn't that cool yeah it's
still weird though it does feel weird
when you ask I mean this isn't weird no
you're not weird thank you I feel like I
feel like we're not we're together I
mean but now it's getting weird I felt
like uh at the Ragnarok rap party it was
the most people I've been around in a
conversational capacity in a really long
time and I was like I don't know if I
know how to do this yeah it's a little
bit strange though but it's nice yeah to
not do it at the zoo we live in the same
city why wouldn't we it's so fantastic
and I got to meet the famous banjo that
is I mean he is here under the internet
the dog of the internet guy
um for anyone who doesn't know you who
are you
well my name is Danielle bassetti I've
been kicking around this town for quite
some time
um to doing some TV doing some film and
um recently uh well actually back in
2014 got a very special audition uh to
do an interactive video game and at that
time I had no idea what that meant do
you know the story right yeah I feel
like everyone does I'll tell it again
I'll get the cliffs notes because it's
like all right we've heard it done y'all
um all I thought of was Avatar or Gollum
I'm like yeah the dots on the face and
the suit that's cool yeah I was like
part without me and Joe
um that's really cool and I love these
universes like growing up like watching
like fantasy and sci-fi I was like I be
thinking I was a fairy and everything
I'm like yeah yeah I can I can Embrace
this got the audition got the sides it
was very like Shakespearean Soliloquy
like Queen like like Lady Macbeth meets
like Khaleesi lady Stark I was like yes
and um God Smiled On Me that day because
I got cast aspreya and got a wharf and
I'm being very sincere like it it has
been an absolute Game Changer in my life
for many reasons not just to be in one
of the most celebrated video games for
obvious reasons it's it's just really a
masterpiece it's a piece of art but it's
fine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we're kind of fans God of Warship that I
have everywhere yeah it's okay yeah
Danielle doesn't like Sony Santa Monica
she never mentions them in a tweet never
I'm like oh my God like now they know
why I got cast aspreya because like when
I like love you and you're in my life
like it's a lot like I'm Italian so like
my my ability to love is pretty pretty
big that makes sense it suits the
character I think Corey got that somehow
got a sense that I was right for her
because as I've been playing her all
these years it feels like my life has
been locked up with her like there's a
simpatico sort of synergy that's
happened in my personal life where I've
been able to channel into what the
brilliant writers have written for her
and it's been a real blessing the time
somebody killed your son there's that
time where I offered my life to my
imaginary son and he you know he always
walked in L.A for a while I did it's
crazy I was quarantined technically that
one's correct yeah like I was relegated
in midgard although it was Brentwood is
a little nicer well kind of nicer than
migr but still she's kind of shitty
during that time yeah yeah it was a lot
but directly related to that I'd love to
ask so you didn't really have a grasp of
what video game acting was was there
anything about jumping into that that
you just totally didn't expect or like
something that like a memory that really
stood out to you as as a unique
challenge that's really specific to
video games
that's a great question
like you should do this for a living
word it myself look at this lady
um I uh
I had never done a voiceover
prior to that okay
um well actually no I take that back
there was one voiceover that I caught
and and I am actually allowed to say
this because they gave me credit I'm I
am sometimes the voice double for Elsa
no way excuse me salsa I've been doing
it since 2010. I wasn't allowed to say
anything what is a voice double mean
well like
like for like for example in the video
game Dreamlight Valley like I went I
voiced her so like you know they're not
always like idina's like off on Broadway
being fabulous I'm like let's call in
let's call in the uh the uh Joe Bag of
Donuts version yeah the poor man's
version of Idina oh but you know what
I'll tell you what being able to be Elsa
and Freya in a lifetime is just like
who all the magic that comes you're very
very good women they're powerful women
it seems cliche it does good well yeah
and also just like leading with a sense
of self and and fully embracing oneself
but not just like that sexuality that
sometimes can be the thing that you know
the Trope of how a woman would lead or
um would present first like I think they
are both very unique I don't think
either of those characters is trippy
which is going to be a blessing as an
actress absolutely yeah because it's not
it's not shaming that aspect like it's
lovely being a woman I mean I love
wearing these hot pink lips but it's
like I don't want to be you know
relegated to just the hot pink lips like
there's so many facets and obviously so
the red lips there are nude just so yeah
like there's the lip balm I mean look at
your look how pretty no come on you're
so gorgeous but what I love is like you
have no lipstick on you just you just
put a little bit of lip balm and she's
like fabulous I'm like it took me an
hour like
well my hair's a [ __ ] mess but my
problem is I'm lazy
I doubt that about makeup about makeup
you are a hard-working like yes forced
to be recorded but I think that's why
it's like
I am always like I would love to put
makeup on and look beautiful every day
and feel beautiful every day but I have
so much [ __ ] to do yeah I get it and I'm
like maybe one day I'll be there totally
I started getting facials recently and
I'm like proud of myself good yeah your
skin is lovely so I totally relate with
that being super busy because now I've
gotten into writing and producing and
whatnot so I'll just like not take off
certain aspects of makeup sometimes they
don't take my eyeliner yeah don't just
don't take it off and then the next day
you're like phew
I have my eyebrows tattooed so that I
don't have to do them see my girlfriend
does that it's really good yeah anyway
this is a separate pod wait gosh guys
I'm so sorry voice overacting yeah so I
had just done that and um that was a
really beautiful gift and then but this
was like interactive so performance
capture right and I I sometimes will be
on Twitter and say actually this is full
performance capture and it's okay to say
voice acting because there are there are
elements to uh God of War uh both games
where we were in the booth and
especially a lot of the times when like
you know you're just like like
traversing a mountain or walking through
you know a door like I need you to just
grunt a bunch yeah and sometimes that's
expositional and I was nervous about a
lot of that because some of the
exposition was very touching like
learning about Calliope and talking
about my my uh background my backstory
um
so
the in the booth and also being a singer
and having that in my background didn't
feel very um I don't know if
intimidating sword it felt like a
natural extension of what I had known
the thing that's a disadvantage of
course in the booth is that you're not
here with a person like the energy we
have here is so much different than when
we're on a zoom yeah so much different
than when I'm in the booth and God love
you Matt sofos you do a great Kratos but
you are no he's not Chris judge my girl
is crazy smell I love oh I just love
Matt and you know and we would laugh
about like Matt is Brock Matt could be
uh mamir Matt was like Sunny he would
have so but reference I believe was is
Rich's narrative director yes so uh yeah
Matt is lead writer no no it's I think
it's the inverse I think it's yeah
reverse oh god well either way they're
both they're both very important to God
of War and wonderful people I love those
guys so much me too I mean like what
they gave Freya that's a whole other
story but anyway so being a voiceover so
yeah so it was like all right I've got
to I mean look I studied the theater
which Chris judge always gives me a hard
time about and I always say that so he
knows yes he always would be like oh
that's the interact or something like
but you know what
I got to like understand a character
from like on a cellular level that
worked for me I'm not saying people that
aren't in the theater can't do that but
like like voice and movement class how
does how does the character move voice
class how where does their voice sit
like based on their past like let me
understand they're not all gonna walk
and sound like me when you're building a
character from the inside out when
you're in a vo Booth do you feel like
you are positioning like is your posture
a conscious decision when you're giving
a performance as well like are you like
you're still trying to stand like the
character 100 it's your whole body
going through that oh yeah and in fact
it so if I have if like if I do a
character that's like sort of a
formidable like like CEO I have to be in
like high heels and like and they'll be
like Danielle the coverage isn't on you
like I'm like no you don't understand
that makes sense I need to be in this
body position to unders feel her
interesting so Freya obviously I was
like flats and always like in like you
know stretchy pants because I was like
moving a lot you know as Freya does um
but yeah so that's so the vo booth for
me was a lot of like when you're um you
know on a blank stage yeah and you're
sort of in this vacuum and you have to
sort of create visually what you're
seeing sonically what you're hearing
like and it feels a little bit like
magic it's almost like on a porous level
you're like sort of absorbing the energy
but also creating that world that's what
it's like for me and thank God I had
someone like Matt sofos who albeit
wasn't all of these characters but
understood these characters so deeply he
knew how to give me those lines yeah so
where sometimes I wouldn't hear Chris's
voice I heard Chris's voice yeah and
we've been do Ed boy and we've been
doing it so long where you could hear
Christmas I know it yeah because we know
these characters now we're so um we're
so integrated
now performance capture is a different
thing right because it's a lot of
technology and like computers like on
your personal comfortable it can be
after a while like there were times
where I just had to take that helmet off
because I could feel the compression in
my spine it was no joke I mean and they
and they would they were Sony's very
sensitive about all the item you know
you take the pack off you know you know
to 15 20 minute break take the pack off
to get the helmet off yeah and I would
always have to like roll down and
stretch out my my vertebrae and I would
hear go because it was like
um another thing that's a little bit
challenging about it is the horn lock we
call it horn locking at least I did so
you've got the helmet and you've got the
camera and it like arcs around like this
to get all of your Expressions yeah
um which by the way that doesn't look
good on anybody like there are moments
what I would be like nobody wants a
camera down you don't and it's down here
and it's something like my dad on
Facebook oh every every picture he has
is that angle and he's gone
I'm like he's not he's handsome man why
Teddy why he just doesn't know any
better yeah you gotta get that but
anyway so sometimes we have these
monitors right and like every now and
then we're like walking around but it's
just like this head moving and it's
really weird and it's like really
obscured but that that's not the point
the point is is that sometimes like I'd
want to hug atreus or like there was a
moment where like Kratos and I would get
closer I'd be like you know I know
you're a God not from these Realms but I
know it and and I'd have to get close to
him but we'd have to make sure that our
horns wouldn't lock and there were times
we would get stuck
that I would say is probably the most
challenging thing about the the costume
as it were yeah I guess you have to be
more aware of this thing you have
sticking out of your head does is that
something that took you a while to get
over or was it easy to jump into like
you have all these dots on your face you
have to wear a really specific outfit
you can't wear the characters outfit
obviously and you're on a stage with a
bunch of Technology around you that's a
very different experience from theater
yes yes you're right and I think I would
attribute it to my skills in theater to
be able to
um imagine all of that away
and see Kratos and feel freya's outfit
or the you know the sword in my back or
whatever it was
um but it did it was it was an
adjustment period of clearly it was I
mean and I'm trying to even remember if
I can if I could remember the first time
I put first of all the velcro is not
comfortable you're constant like when
you have to pee it's not pleasant I mean
you gotta take it down the velcro is
sticking you gotta pee and then you know
it's just like a deal it's a deal but
you get over it I'm trying to think of
that first time on the volume you where
I had that on my person I think I
probably was like oh damn this is this
is a whole new thing but after a while
you get used to it and I was able to
um
yeah almost like a dematerialized and I
just felt like we became and Chris talks
about we talk about this a lot Chris and
I there was such a reverence for the
game yeah like it was bigger than all of
us it really was and it was like I don't
know how it happened like really the
gods of War were smiling because
we walked into the volume and once we
were in that zone and Dory had the no
cut camera and it was like everyone was
like holding their breath yeah
so lovely how did you feel uh like
leading up to release of of Ragnarok
what was that a few weeks like oh so
exciting because you I mean you would
have worked on it for years yeah well
got away since 2014. yeah 2014. God of
War yeah and then to 2018 and then
Ragnarok started 2019 and yeah just
about the same amount of time you know
little things that you just want to
share you just can't wait like I did
this really silly you should see me in a
crown video and by please don't talk
my friend's like you have to some was
like and he's either gonna hit or miss
but I was like you know what I was
really feeling freya's empowerment I was
like you know what no apologies guys
like I earned it I got it back I got the
wings I got my crown I got my title but
it's not if freya's not a boastful
person it wasn't about like flexing it
was like
the soul of who she was had returned you
know and she and I could finally breathe
that in so like when I heard Billy
eilish's you should see me in a crown
I'm like that feels like a Freya song
I'll just do a little selfie video yeah
I respect that yeah but but yeah what
was the the anticipation of it actually
coming out like and how has it been
since well the anticipation was
um huge mainly because I knew what the
story was and I really felt on my heart
of hearts that the gamers that loved it
were going to be so happy they were
going to learn about the mirror they
were going to learn about the the holdra
brothers they were going to learn they
were going to have you know
hey I mean am I allowed to say it am I
allowed to say her name I mean the game
is out like hey I mean this mystical
handprint like I I get so weepy when I
hear memories of Mother by bear Mccreary
and I see that hand print like like a
mother's love is like nothing else and
you get to see her and then and then
yeah you get to learn about freya's
backstory and you get to meet Odin and
she gets to take her power back like I
knew that they were gonna appreciate how
thoughtful the writers were I had no
doubt it was going to look like a like a
freaking
Masterpiece painting I mean I I can't
even the lighting alone is insane to me
like how do you light a video game I
don't even know how they do it I mean I
mean then Roth's team like the
animations the details the veins in some
of the characters faces I'm like that's
a vein I'm sure of it um I could go off
about lighting in video games it's
extremely complicated like how are they
so if they literally put a light in like
it's basically looks like a light bulb
okay but you can say what kind of light
it is like if it's a blanket light it
would just light everything sometimes
it's a light Soul so you have to
physically basically in the engine put a
light inside of a lamp and then describe
its intensity but lighting is one of the
most
um consuming things in a game I always
use the word expensive but really it's
memory intensive okay so the more lights
you have the less of the ship you can
have shows lighting is a really really
complic complicated balance in game
development it's way harder than most
people would think so I appreciate that
you were like that seem so yes I'm I I I
think I wept the first time yeah I'm in
I'm obviously like a big baby I cry at
everything um which is probably one of
the reasons why I was able to have the
emotional um like fragility that Freya
required not that she's um fragile but
just to be able to um empathize yeah but
I remember in 2018 when we had our um
our wrap party I I still was so didn't
even still didn't even know what I was
in had no idea like that the effect of
this game because now I understand it
like I knew what it was like to act it
out and I know what it was like to be an
actor but now I'm thinking oh my God
these players get to embody Kratos they
it's not just sitting in a theater and
going relating this way you're like
physiologically relating like becoming
this person and I walked in and it was
great we said hi everybody this is so
great oh yeah what's gonna happen no
idea and all of a sudden
the characters like popped up on this
huge screen and I was like
holy [ __ ] this is massive so I kind of
liked that I didn't have any
preconceived ideas especially in the
first game because it was all new yeah
so the second game there was more
anticipation because I was like yeah
here it comes baby and I did a few photo
shoots sort of like Freya inspired photo
shoots I saw it's super cool with like
the Raven wings and stuff yeah I wanted
to I wanted to really just Embrace
um her fullness and and they gave me
that in this game they wrote it that way
and I feel like the fans have been
embracing her complete transformation
you know they've seen her go through it
all and I'm I've really appreciated that
Journey so there was like I can't wait
to like start interfacing with them yeah
that was the biggest thing yeah just
waiting for it the God of War 2018
did you have any concept of how popular
that game was going to be no so to you
it was just like oh I'm just doing this
video game I'm just in this video game
yeah and I was like oh there's teal oh I
really liked him in Stargate yeah and by
the way I mean I do I tell this story a
bit too like I was convinced I was gonna
be fired after the first table read
really oh yeah I mean and I'm sure they
were like
look I don't think they were ever going
to fire me I don't want to put that out
there but I think that I had a learning
curve in fact I know I did because I was
sitting up against like this
behemoth-sized man named Chris judge
who's like hello like boy like it was so
and I it was like resonated everything
I'm like and then I got Alistair with
this Scottish bro and then you got
Robert Craig and a new one is thing and
then you've got Aleister who's like I
was like oh wait no these guys really
this is they are voiceover actors the
most normal yeah in a way there's a
voice there's a voice yeah I found her I
had a dream about Han Solo okay did
Corey ever tell you the story no
so I wasn't sure if she was poised or
Regal she was a goddess and a leader of
the banner after all I mean she is the
preeminent is it preeminent goddess of
Norse mythology like she is like she
basically is like all 10 great goddesses
into one the one thing she's not is the
goddess of wisdom clearly she's made
some choices that are come on lady yeah
um
so those were big shoes to fill but I I
was finding her and Corey was so good
with me with that and and Matt and Rich
and the whole team and yeah I really
don't feel like when I'm talking to you
I don't think of Freya in a crazy way
yeah like naturally you are very
different ow cool which I mean maybe you
should be an actress have you thought
about it I've been giving it some
thoughts yeah look into it think about
oh thank you maybe I could like find a
connection please help me out I need
help clearly
um no but uh one day Corey was like
you know what it is he's like
you gotta add a little Han Solo into it
and I was
oh
I went home had my dinner blah blah went
to bed dreamed of Han Solo that night
and like there were some things that
happened with Solo in my dream like
there was an integration period and then
I came back on said I am not joking like
she dropped in interesting yeah it's a
little Han Solo in there sprinkle it
makes sense yeah I get it yeah it's like
the she's got a rogueish charm to hers
on top of everything else which yeah
she's been by herself for 180 years yeah
and I think she learned you know whereas
before it was like the van the leader of
the veneer and then of course becoming a
mother and a wife and all of that and
then it was like
there's a little bit of like yeah you
know F off energy like when she's like
I'm still a God go away yeah she got
there yeah and I finally found her with
a little Han Solo it's crazy how many
creatives get inspired by dreams it
happens all the time yeah what about you
have you had a dream that and because
you're getting into writing and voice
over acting I'm curious yeah so I mean
I've been a writer for 10 years now and
I don't think I've ever dreamed anything
the voiceover also no I wish no what
about that so the character you just
embodied
did you have any dreams about her as you
were like sort of creating
so I wish though it seems like it would
be helpful but I don't really remember
my dreams that much and I look the
struggle I have with acting is like this
I have so many rules because I'm so
limited in what I can do and it took me
a long time to learn that is like I
can't do it if it's my own accent
and that's the thing I obviously have to
figure out but if it's my own accent I
just sound like me pretending to to be
someone else sure if I'm American or
British I can do it if it's me which is
insane yeah like most people like oh I
can't do the accent part right right the
other way around because the minute I
put on an accent I have to become a
different person and um I also I'm just
like as a person who's not very
emotional I'm not good at being
emotionally expressive so basically not
a good actress
Hey listen not all not all characters
need to cry that's the thing is I can do
there's a really specific type that I
can definitely do which is like
um a slightly daria-esque sarcastic yes
a little bit hardened woman I can do
that to a T and I've done it a couple of
times I'm also a great robot if you need
any Roblox can I hear can I hear your
Siri and you can hear mine oh Siri's a
little bit hard because I don't use it
but I mean okay I can do like a GPS
voice which is like a turn left in 300
feet there it is yeah it's a little
staccato yeah yeah there we go Siri Well
mine's British so oh good call from
Alana Pierce oh that is good yeah
okay sorry please call a lot of pears
calling Alana Pierce on mobile
that's very good
FaceTime audio call to Mum that's what
mine says yeah yeah that is good yeah
yeah it's fun robots are fun um I've
done like a lot of like access denied
type [ __ ] there it is
fun but most of it can't do um anyway
yeah my next question was gonna be so
for all of the characters that you've
done you know even outside of Freya do
you have
um like a a homework that you give
yourself to make sure that you
understand that voice like is does every
character require a ton of effort is
some of them more natural like what's
the process for you figuring out how
they speak
yeah that's very that's a very specific
question
um well I so Freya I found I found her
voice once I found her sort of emotional
Center and her grounding like honestly
like her her like feet on the ground was
when the voice got activated
um
and then yeah like some characters are a
lot easier like
um you know if I'm doing a comedy
because I've done a few of those
um I I do sort of play a lot of women
who are a bit affected you know and and
so sometimes there'll be a voice that'll
come out um you know I played the mother
of a death in Insidious chapter two and
that was a that was not my voice coming
through I mean this she was a she was a
specter entity and also just a very
tortured woman who was torturing her
young son dressing him up like a little
girl so yeah this is um I do have to
find that voice and again I think I go
back to I've been doing yoga since 20.
um I'm a dancer so a lot of it is like
physical and then the voice gets
involved I am very studious and you can
talk to anybody at Sony Santa Monica
Studios of all the notes I would bring
in I'm very nerdy like that like I want
to do the research which is why I
thought I'd get fired at the first table
read because I didn't even know what
game I was in um
Corey how could you do that to me we
were literally
everyone says you're a nice guy you
should buy him yeah okay but never heard
of him
never heard of him yeah we like that
joke
um but I found out literally right
before I walked through the doors that I
was in God of War and I still didn't
even understand what that meant I
understood a little more what that meant
but I didn't understand like the scope
yeah but yeah so I think the voice the
movement the body but a lot of it is
also anchored in the backstory so yeah
once I knew she was Freya then of course
I took to the Google The Google verse
you know back in the day we would get
encyclopedias it was very romantic but
now you just like
so I was like Norse mythology and of
course I love mythologies because I grew
up thinking I was already a fairy of
like some capacity or some goddess yeah
so uh
um and so I did all that research and
then I learned about some of her traumas
I'm all I'm always like the way into a
character especially an emotional
character but even a character that can
be hysterical is just sort of like what
happened in that childhood house what's
the defining moment what were the
defining moments exactly was it just one
maybe it was two what what was the
parent that they had the rub with was it
both was it a brother like and then of
course it's a lot of therapy to like get
honest about my upbringing and what
those pains are or you know sometimes
you become the funny one in the family
sometimes you become the victim in the
family sometimes you're the hero of the
family and we play these roles so who is
this character what was their backstory
and then how can I like Infuse you know
my experience into that so did you bring
notes like studious what what are the
notes oh God yeah again Chris is just
like like oh you know I like um I
basically printed out maybe like I don't
know 30 pages from the internet on Norse
mythology on Freya and it's interesting
the prose Etta or the poetica Eda yeah
what do you call it
thank you because she is it Freya with a
J is it Freya without a j is it frig you
know the whole thing yeah
um so there's a lot of that going on and
so I had to sift through a lot of that
I'm like you guys I'm confused you know
because there's all these different like
was it was she Odin's wife Freya Frick
this that the other and of course Matt
and Rich like you're not like they're
basically one like they're like the
brain of the universe like you put their
and then there's Corey he's like I don't
know there's like a cerebral
hey Matt uh quick question he's like
here you go yeah he's like oh yeah no
thank God for that so yeah there I was
little nerdy actress like oh I get to
like do this research and really create
this character but based on this lore
and mythology how lovely yeah and so I
would just take the notes and then I
would build from there and then at the
end of the day you throw it all out
because then once it's like integrated
in your body at least for me it's just
about being truthful in the moment right
so what do I need from Kratos what do I
need from atreus what are they giving me
in the moment you know because you can
think you can overthink and of course I
can do that because I'm some you can
tell I'm like you know going a million
miles an hour
but you can't anticipate
what that living human being is going to
give you in the moment and if you can be
open to it that's like the magic stuff
yeah for sure yeah and I feel like that
yeah I feel if you're bogging yourself
down in too much preparation that could
completely go afterwards yeah I've
learned the hard way sometimes right I
feel like I found a nice balance now in
my life with that at least I think I
have in some in some recent um
experiences with my characters it's
something that we all have to figure out
in the real world as well yeah a
challenge for sure especially when
everyone's got anxiety because the world
is terrible it's a horrible place
um so off of that this is a question
that I love asking people it's like do
you have any advice for people who are
interested in getting into voice acting
or newcoming voice actors like what are
some mistakes maybe that you made early
on that you've learned from or some
something that you go back and tell
yourself when you were first starting
out as an actress what would the the
thing you'd be like Danielle do this
battle stop doing this or learn this is
there any like tidbit regarding wisdom
um
the first thing that just came to my gut
was have your own back
that's coming through right now
I think it's because
everyone has a place and everyone has a
right to follow their dream sure their
passion their talent nurture it
obviously I'm a big fan of going to
school yeah I'm a big fan of learning
your craft
studying those who are your um Your
Heroes Your Role Models
um
surrounding yourself with people who
truly want you to win that's a biggie
because as an artist you're yeah we're
already sensitive beings were human
we're not robots but I mean clearly
Alana is but
so you so things hurt and it's a really
competitive industry and um I didn't
what I didn't know back then was how to
have my own back how to speak up for
myself in situations how to sometimes
let go of friends and people that were
not really there to see me win oh that's
a tough one it's good advice in general
it's just good life advice so like I can
tell you go to school study get get I
mean look at your setup here like invest
in yourself like if you are if you want
to be an actor and a voiceover actor all
of it like you're constantly financially
and time and energetically investing in
yourself
be open to uh criticism like but also
know that you have a point of view you
see sure because you can be so open to
criticism where like you actually uh
Lose Yourself you completely Lose
Yourself
and yeah we're insecure people like
we're insecure because we're human and
life can be scary like I feel like
there's a thing about active
specifically yeah that what you do
has to make people insecure because so
much of the job but again I think people
think acting's way easier than it is
that I now have a lot more perspective
even just doing this podcast
you get some sides you read it you make
a character you submit an audition and
you never even hear back that's it and
they give you two [ __ ] days they
don't tell you if you were if there was
something wrong with your performance
you're just giving it to people and
they're discarding you like it doesn't
matter and then on the day you have
millions of people watching something
that you're doing and you're just
constantly getting notes and feedback to
build this whole it just seems like I I
I don't think it's the insecure people
get into acting
actors have to be insecure because it is
you have to be validated externally to
do your job whereas like a lot of Trades
you don't have to be externally
validated you don't need a director and
all these other actors to care what you
think like if you're doing a dentist or
a doctor yeah yeah because you really do
have to be validated all this it just
seems like a lot it is a lot that's why
I think every you should get a therapist
absolutely get a therapist like I'm I'm
a woman of Faith so like you know if
that makes sense for you or something
where you just feel like hey you know
what you're valuable no matter what the
[ __ ] happens yeah you were put here for
a reason
um I'm like I'm a Christian and now
[ __ ] off you know no but it but it is
true it's like you have to that's why I
said have your own back like you're
valuable no matter what now guess what
you're gonna go out there and put
yourself out there you're gonna audition
you're gonna be rejected I've been
rejected so many times yeah so much more
than I've been validating the fact that
Corey knew I was Freya like he says
within the first 30 seconds is a miracle
it's an absolute Miracle because I
didn't even know what I was auditioning
for but also too because
as an actor you go into everything
feeling like you said just like you said
you're like how would they dress the
hair of the makeup you're getting
memorized then you're sitting in traffic
back in the day when you would go to the
audition but now you got to put yourself
on tape you got to pay for the tape you
got to put you got to edit it together
also social media is a huge thing now
too oh yeah like they're like oh how
many photos do you have like that that
plays into it as well is like you have
to be a social media manager and
marketing it's like are you kidding me
about like wouldn't it back in the day
when it was just really about kind of
just about your talent and your work
ethic perhaps right
um but now there's so many other things
go into it like yeah well we had to give
it to the uh the influencer because she
had more followers but is she an actress
just because you walk and talk doesn't
make you an actor and just because you
can pick up a pen and put a word on a
paper doesn't make you a writer there's
a draft involved yeah now that's not to
say
who do you think you are like I would
never say that everyone get involved if
you want to yeah I think the study thing
is a huge one like I do I do see people
all the time ask for advice for acting
and the amount of people who are like go
to school and people are like but I
don't want to do that other than that
yeah and you're like no no go to school
right yeah if you just want to be famous
then you can do that on Instagram you do
that on PornHub man however you want go
to school that was not for me no but
it's true it is listen it is a shortcut
that is true we we just but you're right
I am a gen xer I was raised in a
generation where it was like you know I
think someone said the other day like
the exers are um grind culture
and I was like oh I didn't know that's
what it was just because instilled in US
was just work ethic like work hard play
hard like you get you get the gain right
um and again there's that magic part
because like we all know that we're not
ultimately in control sure like that's
Insanity like what makes you feel crazy
is when you feel you can like White
Knuckle it it just never works like if
there's that there's um I always call it
like speaking of Freya there's one wing
of effort and I I can I can flap it
until I'm blue in the face but the other
Wing is the wing of Grace and that's the
one that I don't have any control over
but if I'm aware to let that magic come
through to let that perfect timing of
things come through I have found it has
given me a lot more peace of mind in my
life
yeah also agreed to get therapy well
obviously I've done a lot I mean I've
done oh and I've made so many mistakes
sure it'll do it's fine
but isn't that rich because you get to
channel that into your character whether
you're writing it or doing the voiceover
whatever so yeah so have your own that
mental health emotional health um your
tribe of people your I think that's a
really good tip I'm still learning that
right now I would say like the last
several years I've learned or I'm trying
to learn
to to just cut people off if they're
shitty and sometimes I think it can be
really hard to do because I have this
thing where I'm always like oh but
they're going to
go through oh but you know they did it's
okay but if someone's repeatedly shitty
sometimes you have to be like
I don't want to tolerate it anymore and
it's taken me until 29 to finally kind
of put that together and still trying to
figure it out and I wish I could have
done it a long time ago you're way ahead
of the curve I'm trying yeah you are now
you're super impressive I was telling
Alana when we were having our coffee
downstairs it was like the first time I
saw you wait I can't remember but you
were interviewing Corey and you were
with two other dudes podcast beyond
there it was and and of course I was
like you know like I was like oh my God
this game what's happening all this
stuff and I remember I was like just
checking you out like not in that way
but I was like checking out a lot I was
like damn this woman she's just hanging
with the boys
yeah I vomited in that room in the bin
before and after that podcast
um Corey and I were out with other
people obviously until probably 3 A.M
drinking okay and so I went home paused
out in the pants I was wearing on that
podcast
threw up in the in the studio recorded
the podcast threw up again
Lord lady I'd never know yeah yeah it
was uh it was it was an event because it
was GDC I think was why Corey was in
town I'm pretty sure
um and we were at a diner with Nick
Chester who I believe now works at Epic
and a couple of other people
um arguing about which is better between
better Kazooie and Banjo-Tooie
um so that's context for me seeming cool
there big time to cover not at all I'm
super hungry you were so exhausted you
could not be like nonplussed is what
they would put as a writer non-plus not
good you can't yeah I would have never
known yeah that's that's wild I think I
met you at dice that's how you met me at
dice yeah I got to meet I've met some
great these like Lucy James is another
one that I got to meet at the game
awards in 2018 I'm excited to see her
again and just some really cool women in
this in this industry and I felt like
playing Freya was like I think that
these women are going to appreciate what
they've written what they've written and
the opportunity that it gave me yeah
yeah definitely thank you for being free
we appreciate it oh thank you oh yes I
say it's the greatest gift of my life
that has been I'd say it's up there with
one of the greatest Gifts of my life
that's awesome
um I'm going to take you way back okay
how did you start acting in the first
place
so I come from a long line of artists so
it was in my DNA like epigenetics and
all that nerdy stuff I couldn't be more
different my mom is an accountant and my
dad was like a boilermaker or a
Tradesman well I think that might be
where you get your like even Keel like
Vibe too right now probably that I could
explain that off camera for a long time
that's why I'm so even there's a reason
for that but
um yeah that book's like basically just
like
middle lower class regular old jobs and
my mom's very numbers orientated my dad
writes books
um and when I was a kid I've told this
story before but he wrote this series of
kids books when my sister and I it's
called Rosie B and he wrote all these
songs along with it that I could still
sing that he never published it was just
for us which is super cool he even had
art commissions so like there's art for
Rosie B this book that my dad has that I
know Olaf that he just wrote for me and
my sister he's not a good writer is the
thing God bless him but you loved it as
a kid quite bad actually it's no it's
the stories are good okay the stories
are good the writing us back so everyone
has been like Dad he's got this one
story that I that I loved and I'm like
if you finish this I will edit it and we
can make it work like we can make this
happen so that's probably where it came
from but still he's a Tradesman he's
currently like
a building manager like I always feel
like it it the perspective of coming
from a line of artists must be very
different in a household to I think the
perspective that I had sure it seems
weird I don't think I was being super
encouraged to be creative as a kid like
I don't think they were against it but
it was never like an important thing it
must have I don't know it must be nice
it didn't feel like well that's part of
the family tree there you know we that's
what we breed in this family no yeah so
my aunt
um my aunt uh followed a a modeling
career at around 17 and became a pretty
prominent model the time Christina
Ferrari
um came out here had a career then my
dad's aunt my great aunt Helen who God
Rest her soul just passed away
um
she being Crosby it discovered her
because she was a performer and a singer
so one Italian family came down from
Twitter these aren't related no these my
mom and my dad this is how this is how
it was in my blood so my dad's great
aunt like the whole Italian family moved
down from Tacoma Washington to La
Hollywood yeah my mom who was living in
Cleveland they came out from Cleveland
to chase Hollywood and that's how my
parents met well at a little uh grocery
store called the Carmel Market you have
to someone has to write a movie because
this stuff doesn't happen anymore do you
know what I mean I just got chills like
that was really cute yeah two Italian
families coming together and um having
success in the industry so I see that
like and I I say it a little bit like
not not fully removed but it's in my
blood but it wasn't like I was born into
a family where it was like the doors
open Danielle right this way to CAA like
we're gonna put you in kid like I have
definitely worked but it was always
encouraged and supported and it was it
was what it was we're a family of
entrepreneurs and artists so does that
mean like when you were younger you were
exploring drama even at school yeah you
were in like places okay so yeah I'm
like long-winded as fun I was like wait
a minute the answer is it was in my
blood at about four my mom showed me the
Wizard of Oz clearly I needed to be
Dorothy I asked my entire family to go
into the backyard and reenact the entire
movie everybody was game I have my
little basket and my little stuffed
animal Toto that's amazing and at that
point I was like do you have any
pictures of that I wish I I think so
I'll bet you there could be something I
could find oh my God and I just knew I
was like this is my world people that's
awesome that was it so it was basically
like the that was the job that you
wanted the whole time from day one
awesome like I feel like it's a lot of
people struggle to find themselves for a
long time and actually I don't think
that's that uncommon with actors though
you know I think I think that
I know rahul's the same for my kid
wanted to be an actor and that's all
they ever wanted to do he's so good
yeah he's all right we like him the
accent is nice yeah
I'm a sucker I'm a total anglophile like
I'm a bashing I love the British she's
got it you live in London I mean it's
like when we were there in the Baptist
at 2019 I was like again I was like this
is my place I've never been
Colin even though half of my family is
British uh meaning that I could get a
passport
yeah I still can't super easily I could
have I could lift that fine but I've
never been just okay well 2023 yeah come
on I really my um football club
Liverpool I would really love to go see
them play I've been wanting to do that
for a really long time so I got plenty
of reasons to go there there's nothing
yeah you do I think you're gonna Thrive
there I can see I'm sure I love it I
have another very coat in your scarf and
right after the bath does I think which
is totally incredible I mean what an
honor and like just almost like other
worldly to like be a part of that and I
remember being on that carpet with with
them and I was like this
this get felt so surreal but also too
felt it felt it's like two parts one
feels earned because I know
I know how hard I work for it official
but then the other part of it is just
again it's that Grace part it's like
this is a complete gift that
um I I just I'm like bowing and I'm
kneeling and I'm like they'll keep God
for this moment in my life like I feel
the same way about the same studio and
that like I've been writing my whole
life I went to school study writing yeah
um I've been a professional writer for
12 years total now and I walked my ass
off to get hit but I'm still like holy
[ __ ] I'm here you are the Pinnacle yeah
the Mountaintop of video game writing
all the time I'm like I can't believe
they pay me I feel like I should be
paying them to let me work that like all
the time I'm like I just get to ask
anybody questions about any of this all
the time it's two years and I still feel
that way so I don't know if it'll ever
stop feeling that way exactly having the
same experience I'm like I know I work
super hot I know I deserve to be here
but also oh my God so thankful I'm here
right yeah you're like a little weak in
the knees and a little trembly yeah I
feel that every time I go into the
office which I do you know fairly often
I'm still like
that's how I would feel going in a
Disney Animation oh yeah I got to help
well I would say help the writers not as
a writer but um I would avoid I voiced
Elsa during the exploration of Frozen
two gotcha so like yeah idina's not
gonna come in every time they're trying
to figure out does the scene work or not
and working that Academy award-winning
team and walking into Disney Animation I
would literally pinch myself every time
and I would try to play it cool like but
I don't think I I'm I'm a fan girl at
the end of the day like I'm so nerdy and
I'd be like cool guys it's really cool
to be here
Disney wait is that how you pronounce it
I've heard of this like uh you know ice
making Queen
um no but I mean there are moments where
we I would be acting out these scenes
and all of us would have tears in our
eyes wow and that was really powerful
it's like yeah I know I know that this
is it idina's and I have I like I'm I
like have the utmost respect for her but
I also got to be somewhere a part of
that journey and that was a huge gift
that is awesome yeah and I I did you
have any
goals when you first started I was an
actor of like a thing that you wanted to
do because I feel like for a lot of
people Disney I really want to voice my
own Disney character I mean like I feel
like that's that's where the roads are
gonna gonna lead and at some point it
will make sense to to do that um I I
sing musical theater I have all that
stuff so I know how to put that on yeah
um yeah yeah and I just again it's a
trust thing I mean I want everything
yesterday I mean I don't know who
doesn't maybe it's like you you know you
have that ambition and that desire and
you're like I got so much in me um but
then there's also that wing of Grace of
like all right well you know what it
will happen at the right time and it
will always surprise me it'll always
surprise you and then you'd be like oh
that's the thing yeah yeah 100
um so to again take you back from yeah
it makes sense how you wanted to become
an actor when you were turning it into a
career what were the steps like you went
to school you wanted to be an actor the
whole time
how did you actually turn it into a job
because that process is a lot more
complicated than a lot of other
disciplines exactly right like when you
graduate high school and they don't
teach you how to balance a checkbook
you're like that would have been really
helpful taxes taxes what oh wait I can't
just charge up this credit card and
magically dad's not gonna pay does it
make sense some daddies do I wish yeah I
know right like ah daddy
um
so graduated got my Bachelor of Arts
felt
um really prepared creatively but um had
no idea how to broach the business
aspect of it and I found a company I
don't know if they're still around
called AIA actors
that sounds familiar yeah
yeah
AI AC was a a Studios or AIA Studios and
and what they did was they were that um
intermediary like they were sort of like
the bridge between hey I just graduated
theater school and I don't know there it
is completely closed oh you know what
but I think that there's some
organizations out there that like so
look like could just be the office says
that though yeah
they exist right you can do blind
submissions maybe you have a great look
maybe you I tell people this all the
time get your iPhone and shoot a short
totally Empower yourself out the gate
yeah yeah yeah that latest iPhone
has like an auto
um not auto focus because that's normal
it does like the portrait mode but with
videos now it's incredible wow I shot
this they just like recorded something
that Rahul
um
because he was building a desk and I
recorded it and I could put the the
footage up just this
is like short quality
but it's just an iPhone of him building
and then we just edited it with music
look at him he's a Craftsman
well yeah he definitely is but like
isn't that pretty it looks fantastic
they're like damn this phone like this
is the one that came out this year I was
like you could absolutely shoot a
brilliant shot with that like and I
think that's been my biggest piece of
advice for anything creative ever or
throughout my career is just do it just
do it just do it it doesn't matter if
it's bad no because I started making
short films so my first one was
um an exercise in
I only have a day it's covered so it was
me and one other person that's it and
only one set and I was like these are my
restrictions what can I create and I
made something and I think what I made
is like not a compelling story but it
was an exercise in can we make this with
these restrictions and I think that
almost makes you get more creative 100
and just do it you could do it tomorrow
you do it in a day like it's just do it
realm wasn't built in a day that's so
you're laying bricks you're literally
building your foundation like yeah I say
get a theater training that's my that's
what I would tell you but you know
there's lots of great uh teachers out
there in LA there's lots of great you
know acting for the camera learning
learning I mean that was a big
adjustment right like in the theater
you're a bit bigger with your voice and
your expressions and then you know when
you're in film and it's right here you
know just just to look up and tell you
those videos
for your Expressions well there is
twofold right because part of it is
physical they want to see the way Freya
moves in these scenes but then the
camera is literally right here so just a
quiver of the lip you know or just like
the tear that comes down or just the you
know just the exhale all of it's
literally being captured
which actually gave a lot of freedom
because I felt like it doesn't matter
how big I go or how small I'm gonna be
captured in this entire take with the no
cut camera right how brilliant you know
Dory is and all of them for creating
that feeling of like extremely difficult
we're pulling you by the lapels of your
shirt and we're not letting you go for
40 hours oh my Lord
um so yeah so take the workshops learn
the techniques of acting for the camera
get in the theater get into voice and
movement get into yoga do all these
things as far as like finding an agent
um that is a hurdle that's a tough one
right um sometimes you can ask for help
you know sometimes you can submit a
scene it get some good scenes of
yourself on tape now it's I mean again
there really aren't a lot of excuses
for being able to emancipate yourself
that way whether or not the door opens
it is some I I some people say luck you
know like I think it's life path stuff
and I think it's like you know but um
you got to put it out there and like you
said a lot of like maybe the maybe it's
gonna be [ __ ] for a minute like and
maybe and you can objectively like
almost remove yourself and be like Oh
okay that's working that's not working
you know work with yourself like love
yourself enough to be like yeah I'm
gonna just finish this oh and that's
what I want to say you said something so
important when you finish something
you're actually building self-esteem
right yeah and it could and you could
look at it and be like you know what
yeah I like kind of like it but I'm not
crazy about it but it wasn't good you
have the accomplishment of the fact that
you did it you finished it yeah it's do
it do it yeah all these things matter I
wish I had like the genie in the bottle
and been like
CAA you know they're like entered I
always imagine them like the golden
gates like enter we've got it all from
taken care of from here and you're like
phew because I'm exhausted that was hard
oh it was really hard to hear everyone
disliked that yeah that Journey was yeah
um the pilgrimage the pilgrimage of an
actor it's a journey it's a journey it's
a journey for sure yeah so
I guess like something that I've seen
people talk about doing is submitting
just their own self tape of um like a
Shakespearean monologue that resonates
with them highly and then they submit
that and literally people have gotten
agents that way like they're fantastic I
guess you just have to be creative find
options and then you can you can just
submit things
by doing the research to an agent who's
looking yeah absolutely yeah and a lot
of times it's not personal like oh we've
got someone like you and that's true
it's like they have a certain amount of
hours during the day the second that you
can really Embrace that it's not
personal because it feels so personal
like you said it's like oh my god I
didn't even hear anything I I had tears
in that audition I was brilliant and
like crickets but then that's great
advice I didn't I didn't I mean imagine
that now yeah you can just put your best
foot forward make sure you're well lit
make sure you're well hurt certainly
don't turn in [ __ ] you can make
something and and learn from it but what
you know you never get a second chance
for a first impression and that and that
really does apply a lot of time so yeah
do what do your strength show show your
bet put your best foot forward and um
it'll come around it'll come around so
my last question because I gotta let you
go yeah you do I gotta I gotta get to
Santa Monica it won't take that one
um my last question was going to be
we've spoken about a lot of you know the
struggles and challenges just what's
your favorite thing about being an actor
what's the number one favorite thing
how getting to express aspects of myself
that I don't
feel as liberated to do
in in real life are what is it IRL in
real life just trying to be cool like it
was very cool of you I didn't stumble at
all
very great delivery super cool wow I
feel like I'm being pandered too okay
um
you know I I get to play pretty powerful
women sometimes formidable I always do
try to find their vulnerability and and
their their um the flaw or the the wound
I think it's really important
um a lot of times you know you can play
what's on the page and you can be it's
like putting white on white like you can
just really bite into the words but
that's not quite likable I one of the
things that I've enjoyed a lot is by
playing these I call them complex women
women with complexities I don't think
that they're heroes or villains but you
you never approach a character you can
hear anybody like you don't you know
Christopher Waltz like right like in in
glorious bastards like you're not
approaching a character like you're the
villain you you are the hero of the
story and sometimes that means you are a
psychopath like depending on what the
character is but like why is that person
that way and so the short version is the
psychology behind it all and then the
ability for me to exercise aspects of
myself that I didn't necessarily feel
like were safe to express in my own life
for sure yeah you almost get to have
like a little bit of therapy is a job a
little therapy writing is super simple
and some artistic lessons yeah and
writing oh my God writing is first of
all it's the hardest thing you'll ever
do it's not easy but it's also so
empowering because you are create you
are the god of that Universe yeah
it's pretty cool yeah I'm gonna ask a
small follow-up question even though I
said I wouldn't okay
curious yeah so does all of the you know
digging into trauma and the way the
characters come from do you look at
people in your real life differently
like do you ever meet somebody and think
about them in terms of like 100 sure
they're interesting I will tell you the
the there's an empathy
actions can be heinous sometimes we
don't like actions that hurt other
people
um
but when you step when when you make a
when your life is studying characters
and and you're you got to understand why
yeah why you're saying this why did now
of course you're saying it because the
writer wrote it but you have to
understand as a character like why am I
saying that so sometimes you can someone
can be a real dick and you're like God I
wonder what his dad was like today
yeah yeah I wonder what that was like
you know sometimes you don't like the
behavior but that you can have a little
compassion sometimes yeah I'd say that's
pretty valuable
a great note to end on have a little
compassion sometimes just a little
compassion the the
um all this Huxley famous writer uh he
wrote A Brave New World is probably the
one he's most famous for he said he was
trying his whole life to figure out what
the meaning of life was and then he'd go
to the end of his life and he figured it
out he was like 70 and he was like it's
embarrassing the meaning of life is
embarrassing but I figured it out be a
little kind of that's what he thought
the meaning of life was just be a little
kinda that's it I was like okay that's
what he figured out it's a guy who's
like nominated for various like
humanitarian Awards and wrote 70 books
Super Famous be a little kind of
that's it that's a beautiful isn't it go
out on it
anyway thank you for joining me yeah
where can people find you it's pretty
easy it's always at Danielle basuti
there's like that's not a very common
last name so I didn't have to put a one
or a two or you know a social media
privilege yeah right there aren't a lot
of cities out there but yeah and I'd
love to interface with you there and um
thank you to the fans who who love this
game and who have in particular been
really supportive of Freya on her
journey like it means so much
awesome I will leave a link in the
description so you can check out
Danielle talk about Freya and how much
you love her as we all do of course
thank you see you all next time bye
pleasure isn't she amazing
she's my favorite robot
[Music]
thank you